hey folks we're back with another
episode of wild ride with steve-o and I
think this week there's a lot of media
paying very close attention so how about
we get right into it with the light
heavyweight champion of the world
ladies and gentlemen Jon Jones the champ
is here in Albuquerque New Mexico were
parked outside of John Jones beautiful
mansions overlooking the sound Sandia
Mountains it's got a guest house what's
the Stephanie Lowe mansion ah probably
this place you bought this house from
Holly home I bought this house from
Holly Holm and her dad Roger yeah when
it's been creeping up in three years now
okay all right yeah so what does that
mean that when she knocked out Ronda
Rousey she thought it was time for an
upgrade yes I got that great for her for
sure she wasn't living here she sold you
the house yes yes I'm sorry yes she sold
me the house she's a real estate agent
and if she did live here that'd be
pretty cool too it's a good thing she's
got a day job after the whooping I gave
her yes that was it was it was like if
you know if I got in front of a car you
know like it was the same so know how
this came to happen John we reached out
to me last week yeah yeah I I've been a
big fan of the power of momentum you
know we have great ideas to not sit on
them but to just go for it and I have
this group called the Care Project where
we are nonprofit in Albuquerque New
Mexico stands for community appropriate
relief effort you beat me to it
good job Steve oh yeah and I know that
you've spent time in Albuquerque I've
been in several shows here in
Albuquerque which are awesome by the way
like two and a half years yeah 96 98
yeah man I know that I see the turnout
people that comes to your shows and I
know you got a lot of
querque so I just thought I'd give you a
call man use that momentum and just see
what's the worst thing that can happen
you can say no right it was so awesome I
remember I was at the skate park I'm
gently trying to get some tricks and all
the sudden my phone's ringing in my
pocket I look at it says it says Jonny
bones Jones I'm like dude I'm getting a
call from John Jones right now all right
what's up dude he said hey man like I
got this new it's new initiative this
charity where we're cleaning up
Albuquerque we're doing all these things
to help out the people and and I wonder
if you could get behind it and I said
dude why don't we get together and and
film something together to make it
happen
I'll be there next week next week and
then that put that that was last week so
I come out here we have made news all
over the place yeah man you're many are
worthy of our respect there every Dave I
just got out because the news people
were expected nah I just got a text from
my guy you know when I got a story I
contact TMZ try and I told him I said
absolute exclusive human fiction or said
I am such and this got this got
published like minutes ago says wanna
see steve-o Ollie over the greatest MMA
fighter ever good cuz TMZ sports has
obtained video of the former Jackass
star star boarding over John Jones at a
New Mexico skate park this week and it's
both awesome and terrifying oh yeah
check out the footage Jones laid down on
a ramp and let steve-o skate over him
and the first attempt nearly cracked
John's ribs by the way if you're
wondering why the duo are spending time
together in New Mexico it's all for a
great cause
steve-o joined the UFC champ to help his
efforts with the Care Project raising
money and support for communities
impacted by covet 19 pandemic in New
Mexico steve-o was a massive UFC fan and
has been a regular at UFC fights for
years what that's big man absence in man
absolutely it felt so good to get to
bring some acknowledgement to the care
project man and and to have you come
back and support and to bring exposure
in such a positive way doing a stunt and
giving back to the community it's gonna
be huge but I really hope this this cure
project thing just takes off and
everybody in the community wants to be a
part of it at some point and then that's
that's my goal I want to be the biggest
nonprofit in Albuquerque and and have it
to where every ever every other
nonprofit that needs anything whether
you're the Boys and Girls Club or not
I'm not sure if they're nonprofit or not
but whether you're the Boys and Girls
Club or a food bank I want the care
project to have their hand in every
company so that that they need
absolutely nothing I want to provide for
it for this whole town and this all came
about that night when you saw it you
taking this spray cans out of people
major riots going on looting people are
just being disrespectful of the City of
Albuquerque and then you see on the news
John Jones in the streets and like just
[ __ ] people forcibly taking away
spray cans from kids that are like you
know trying to destroy property and
saying look that's disrespectful to our
city I'm mad too but this isn't the way
and like that got the attention of the
whole world yeah I think I think what it
I think it stood for an idea we're
saying people all over the world
looting cities and taken over police
stations and and and I think what the
Care Project well we weren't the Care
Project then but I think what I
represented that night was an idea of of
civilians standing up and saying hey not
in our city you know who knows what
could have happened in Albuquerque if
the care project wasn't created or that
that message wasn't send that that right
people you know the message that was
sent was that you know we're not gonna
stand by while the police stay three
blocks away we're not gonna just stand
by and watch you spray paint and watch
you whatever you want to do the missions
got really clear that there was gonna be
a group of men that's gonna speak up and
sure enough man we you know I've got 30
men to go out and
and cotton police are protest and this
was on a following night I was surprised
did you take spray can away yeah and
then like maybe like the next night like
whatever it's a couple days later I
started on all the MMA you know YouTube
videos now you've got like a whole crew
of 30 people you see weapons you see
like route to here but nobody's messing
with our city tonight and I know a lot
of people got a little bit uncomfortable
seeing that because it felt a little bit
vigilante yeah yeah so we we walked it
back for me to come out here and we what
we did was we went the complete opposite
route the first night we went out we had
30 men with us and we did go out as a
nonviolent group what we did also have
about five over 30 guys have their
sidearms just for security for the group
members you're not not to approach
protesters you know were you worried at
all for your safety when you're out
there oh absolutely absolutely and
people thought we're police officers cuz
we did some job jackets on and stuff
like that I was definitely worried for
my safety but we made it real clear that
we are nonviolent and that we were here
with the people we were they're a part
of the protest but we also wanted to
represent our community well by having
peaceful nonviolent
non non you know vandalizing type
rotation so and it worked it worked we
only had to show up one time as as over
Watchers and I think the message was
sent we we actually kind of apprehended
someone that night and took cans from
another group of people that night had
searched their car for more cans and
found more cans we only had to do that
one time and I think the messages were
sent that you know John Jones and and
the care group are out here and if the
police are gonna state blocks away
these guys will will do something to you
themselves you know we're not gonna hurt
you or anything but a bunch of crawfish
CrossFit athletes and power lifters and
UFC fighters fighters you know yeah
asking you to not do that you may be may
stay home I'm surprised it took the kids
so long to give you as can I mean you
could use like get over here like yeah
you're the older brother like hey idiot
you know it was a surreal moment you
know cuz every act of aggression or
I've done every eye I'm a very laid-back
peaceful chill do you know I never get
confrontational I don't like to argue so
anytime I get that that feeling of anger
is it's usually in a UFC situation so I
hadn't I haven't I haven't been in a
street fight since Daniel Cormier I
don't get in arguments face-to-face
conversations like this iam gran and in
the arena few years ago back and I'm
sure a year that was but yeah did it
beat it was the first one
yeah the first fight yeah the first time
we faced off we worked forehead to
forehead and he shot me in the throat I
ended up pushing him over tackling him
off the stage it was crazy yeah I
thought I thought the best of them he
ended up taking off his dress you and
winging it across the room trying to hit
me in the face to get the last lick and
ended up hitting a female reporter in
the head instead it was crazy that's not
good moments later we go backstage and
we get in this heated argument and then
that's when there's this famous hole are
you still there [ __ ] hey [ __ ] are you
still there have you ever heard that
light nah he's like I just want to
[ __ ] spit in your yeah yeah their
form is like I will end you I was like I
absolutely kill you yeah if you do that
a sec you think I'm just gonna sit there
let you kill me Jon Jon's whole argument
with it was clearly by 2016 or before
right because I only really became like
the die-hard UFC Fan like around that
time and since and I guess that doesn't
make me very diehard but man I don't
miss a fight are you you draw a Yuna
you DC cool now or just yeah I respect
DC III I think he's an outstanding man I
I think he represents himself very well
I think he represents african-americans
very well I think he reps that you will
see very well being a father being an
athlete you know he's very well-spoken
he's a great commentator his analysis of
fights is just so fantastic and for that
matter everything every one of them
every
Dominick Cruz Joe Rogan they kill it
they got the best chemistry
when the analysis just the knowledge
like okay now he's gonna like you know
you're gonna swivel his hips is gonna
who knows what they're watching yeah
they're so articulate and so like just
impressive I could do that like a kick
and then a veni punched him four times I
would be being biased and siding like to
subconsciously siding with people like
oh could you have her like scotch people
and stuff that's why I would go over
especially if you knew him too yeah yeah
exactly it'll be you know obviously I
was rootin for you're super articulate
guy have you thought about getting on
the commentary scene before Jon Jones
gives his commentary on commentary let
me tell you about what I'm wearing on my
right wrist it's called a whoop strap
and it's a fitness tracker which
provides more insight into your overall
health than any other device out there
this thing works with an app and it's
constantly giving me information like
for example sleep the exact amount of
REM sleep deep sleep
how many disturbances there were plus
all of my exercise activities my heart
rate variability there's so much
information and I'm able to have groups
of my buddies so that we can compete
over who's doing more exercise who's
sleeping better who's in overall the
best health it's just plain killer and I
have no plans of ever taking it off
because I don't have to you see I carry
the charger in my pocket at all times it
slides right on and boom it's charging
the thing is just so killer I cannot
recommend it enough it works as a
membership service gives all kinds of
cool perks like the strain coach the
recovery coach constantly giving you
information about how you can improve
your health and if you go to whoop calm
that's WH Oh Opie calm and use the promo
code steve-o you're gonna get 15 percent
off at checkout again I can't recommend
it enough so again it's use promo code
steve-o at whoop calm for 15% off at
checkout and you
gonna thank me for it now let's get back
to the commentary no no not at all why's
that um I don't know man I'd like to act
I like Jews well I think that that's
sort of like you know pushing the same
boat yeah give it a shot man yeah I
wouldn't be buying I wouldn't mind doing
something like doing like a guest
hosting gig or something like that but
well the most part I've always had it in
my heart to be in a movie
I think my daughter's really proud and I
think that a little bit of commentating
would like help facilitate that you know
it's in front of the camera not fighting
like would it be like an action movie
were to be like the notebook I could see
myself doing something like a military
role to start off just to get my feet
wet you know being able to wear like a
military uniform and be like an elite
squad member of some SEAL team or
something like that I would love that
you know some real simple lines for just
to start me off and you know I think I
think if you're right down my alley
I mean it's always been a dream would be
worried about though that I see that
most people that get into acting don't
really do well in their next fight so
would you want to wait till you're done
fighting is that fair to say I mean
their correlation between people [ __ ]
around with with anything that distracts
them and that's probably a good reason
to not even be worried about the
broadcasting in a commentator yeah
because it's like you know let me keep
my head in the game and not you know I I
think that I think that I will when I do
get into acting I would want to do it
wholeheartedly I'm not I would like to
take like a movie role like sometime
soon just exist to try like being an
extra having a small role like I was
just saying but to like actually pursue
a full-time is one I think I'll get into
that when I retire I want to hire an
acting coach and and do it take the same
approach that second to my mixed martial
arts career and to acting and with
commentary another reason why I haven't
really tried to pursue opportunities get
into that and it could be a subconscious
thing I don't want people to get into my
psychology too much while I'm still an
active fighter or I feel like if you're
smart enough
you couldn't listen to I always say if
you want to know what's in a man's head
you just listen to what comes out of his
mouth and you'll start to get a true
sense what's going on in his head right
that's going so so so meet me explaining
the way I see positions and things like
that I think I'll give people a little
bit of my sight yes exactly I want them
to think that it's just my long arms
that makes me win yeah all right so we
come up to your house and by the way
it's so hilarious like camped out in
front of John Jones and I was so many
things so much more friendly right now
and and right when we pulled up parked
the RV get out and you're covered in
sweat you just got back from mountain
biking with your endurance coach your
endurance coach says to you yo man our
top speed was 39 miles an hour and and
that's like biking on a mountain bike
down a mountain yeah it's pretty
dangerous for my experience level for
sure I mean there was there was some
cyclist who would probably go way faster
than that but to be on mountain bikes
and me bein an amateur that was the
fastest I had ever gone and baby steps
man so yeah I loved it
my first thought was like dude that
guy's on your team he's putting you in
that kind of danger I'm serious but I
thought like should I see John think
about firing this guy what we've been
realizing is that biking mountain biking
and biking it correlates it translates
over into fighting a live wrestling and
I'm actually trying to get my little
brother Chandler Arizona Cardinals
football player to start my mountain
biking a lot more I'm noticing that I'm
spending so much time and this hunched
over bent over position where my knees
are kind of bent I'm not standing
upright and and it's a lot like an
aggressive attack position like that's
fighting or shooting in for a double
like dive or something like that so I
feel like my knees are getting stronger
and more healthy it's complementing my
power lifting a lot and I think what
he's getting I was like it's it's if you
fall you're [ __ ] oh I would be thanked
for sure so it's not like you're
swimming laps or something like that
like well that's no it could be a career
changer that's another thing the hey
that coordination type of thing when
you're on a mountain bike you have to
you have to be totally engaged with how
fast you're going is the gravel loose
you know is it gonna is this bike gonna
tell whip on when I try to turn this
corner this Boulder is coming up in my
left I got a jump and I gotta make it so
it's it's you you know you're your eyes
and your and your your brain and your
body's all moving it's it's so good for
you man is that like fast twitch muscle
twitch muscles reaction time I think it
enhances so much I really recommend it
alright I think you'd like mountain
biking luck Steve cycles you know I mean
you've been BMX in your life
why do the the road bike okay it's cool
it's but I didn't you never got into
grinding and bikes
okay skateboarding I got a question for
you okay I can't read what just went
through this trip I came to the mountain
bike where we're here we'd like John
Shuster of course is good so then the
next morning we wake up and it's like we
go to Jackson wink this is like the most
Jackson wink is your training facility
steered your coach we train it's I it's
I think American Top Team is pretty well
known but Jackson wink is we've been up
there
we've been up there for a long time
there are some teams that are definitely
as known as US and they're getting
really big and as of today we may not be
the best team in the world but over the
last decade we have been in the top
three top five and so yeah we're legit
we got guys from all over the world that
comes in and and Holly home we got we
got some new guys that are coming in air
and pìkô a guy named Patchi these were
Bellator athletes that I think could
compete for the UFC world title right
now yeah I saw her running in and she
was just dripping sweat and then she
went into kicking Steve's ass and then
she went into like hitting bags and [ __ ]
well I was home she trains about five or
six times every single day I hear
there's like a disease like a workaholic
disease where people like worked
themselves into she could have it man
she is she she runs she told me
yesterday she has this goal to run a
hundred miles a month a hundred miles oh
man she runs and for UFC fighter I think
that's ridiculous
she does CrossFit type workouts she's in
shape she hits rip Winkeljohn three four
times a day sometimes and she's always
in the gym and she's very humble
she's very humble in it see I respect
that the most about Holly
Holly's one of the most recognizable
people in Albuquerque so everywhere she
goes
in Albuquerque I'm her cameraman
automatically look can you take a
picture of me and Holly no really man
people love her here she had a parade
27,000 people showed up to her parade
after she beat around the Rosie yes and
the way she just so gracious with every
single fan man it's it's really it's
really special how she does what
celebrity we got we got some of them
some of the news that we made since
we've been here like Holly that was one
that's out all over the place so then we
go from the gym when we go to Walmart we
buy like like two thousand dollars worth
of towels underwear toiletries all the
stuff works yeah and would you go around
gave it to ya we got to go to tint town
this is a place I've never been more
just tent town was next to the skate
park where we did the terrifying ollie
oh yeah and then we went from there to
go jump off of
I want to go jump off this building back
when I lived in Albuquerque it was a big
deal for me this three-story roof and
off the roof I did a front flip into
five feet of water and almost 25 years
later I asked myself could I do it again
and I didn't want it I'm glad I did and
I came out here to help the City of
Albuquerque so we've got this one frame
sequence of like one photo of the
building but I'm there there there
there's like ten of me doing this front
flip off the building it's incredible
and to help the Albuquerque Food Bank up
shout out to wolf Fox Photography by the
way all Fox yeah what are you gonna do
with that poster do you I'm gonna make
it I'm gonna make card stock eight by
ten sign every single one of them and
sell them on my social media platforms
and 100% of the proceeds go to the
Albuquerque Food Bank because people
have been listening to this
guests have heard me say it breaks my
heart that with the corvid pandemic the
people like our food insecure the idea
that people can't eat like I want to do
something and so finally here I have
this initiative I think that I might be
able to some of those autographed
pictures potentially raised like a
hundred thousand dollars for the
Albuquerque Food Bank what do you guys
think at home you guys gonna buy a
single shot and be people at the same
time yeah I know that Tony Hawk raised a
hundred and twenty-five thousand dollars
doing exactly the same thing I'm just
copying Tony Hawk's model and and he did
it for a cove it wasn't food bank
specific but it was a cove aid relief in
general they say if it's not broke don't
fix it
alright tell me about your relationship
with Tony Hawk you've mentioned him a
few times I love the guy before I talk
about Tony Hawk let me tell you about
what I'm doing right here I'm harvesting
my pubes and you see I've been
collecting my pubes for just about two
entire years so that I can make a
Sasquatch suit out of them well you know
shaving my pubes got a whole lot easier
once I was introduced to manscaped no
more nicking my balls bleeding from my
privates now perfectly comfortable cut
free and grooming is a treat
plus you know they've just launched
command scaped in canada so all you
hairy Canadians can get your act
together a girl doesn't want to see that
bush you gotta get down there and groove
it yeah
plus I'm never gonna have any hair
coming out of my nose or my ears because
of the manscaped weed whacker yeah if
you don't have man escapes lawnmower 3.0
and the weed whacker then he just gotta
get your act together and it's easy to
get it too because if you go to manscape
dot-com use the promo code steve oh
you're gonna get 20% off your order and
free shipping and I'm tellin ya if you
if you're cutting your balls the way I
used to
man life is gonna be a lot better once
you get into the manscaped way of life
so enjoy and one one more time manscape
comm used the promo code steve-o for 20%
off your order and free shipping now
let's talk about the Birdman what is it
about him that inspires you I mean he's
just such an icon he's such a legend of
course I'm just a fan and having grown
up in a skateboard and it's a good dude
and our jackass family came from the
world of skateboarding and going back to
the very beginning when it was just a
little skateboard magazine any time that
any of us ever reached out to Tony Hart
to ask him to do something without
question a hundred percent he was there
he did it and and sometimes it involved
like making fun of him like he's just
like he's very like self-deprecating
he's he's happy to be the butt of the
joke he just doesn't take himself
seriously and I mean like and we can
help each other sometimes he reaches out
to me hey do you know you want to be a
part of this thing always a hundred
percent yeah and vice versa so we just
have this relationship hey that's cool
and I really our relationship is like
that it's this fantastic like the these
worlds collide because like when I'm
jumping off that building yesterday John
Jones is flying the drone Charlie's the
drone camera back Joe is that a Mavic -
I got this we had local Albuquerque news
crew following us around - so and and
John's like John says to the news guy
hey man this jumping off the building
thing probably goes probably not legal
and and we probably don't want you to
cover it because we don't want to
reflect badly on the care project and
I'm like cool this I got this I'm taking
responsibility for this and I didn't
even know that I thought that was
something separate from the whole help
Albuquerque and it turns out that might
be the biggest oh yeah stunts is what
put you on the map
first place so for you to come back to
Albuquerque where you grew up or where
you spent time and freaking jumping off
a building that you've done 20 it just
it just it came out great
it wouldn't be Stevo coming into town
let's leave all did something wild all
right so I'm glad you did it man just
gonna say you put your health on the
line to raise awareness but now you say
you're gonna do it no matter what so I
take that back I visited the building
they climbed on the roof I looked at it
and I was like man that's shallow I'm
six feet tall and that pool is five feet
deep I'm not sure if you've talked to
anyone about your one two three and I'm
like okay
I'd like I assess it and then I don't
there's no getting myself to do it and
then I'd but I just have this trick I
count one two three go and when I've
done that I've never backed out in my
life of anything and we got to watch it
go once you started coloring it you know
what I'm gonna do that I feel that
people can take that and just implement
that in their own lives you know I mean
just dare yeah one of my favorite songs
well it's not one my favorite something
but I I love that song I hope you dance
by who I came to think of the lady who
sings it but I listen to it all the
sides like I hope you still feel small
when you stand beside the well I think
it's a great song cuz that's dancing
that's like you know I hope you take
that dance I hope you ride the bull' I
hope you freakin you know what I mean
that's that's living that's a good and
people can live people can learn
something from that you know what he did
yesterday was superhuman like climbed up
climbed down and then after we got done
giving away all the the care packages I
said to you I don't ever want to say
this out loud but that roof I told you
about is point three miles away John
says let's go John Reed thinks it like
man I don't know if this is legal but
dude it worked out great man it worked
out great I'm saying I don't
this is illegal once you're living in
strange times what's happening you're
all grown up now I don't know what's
happening and then just to bring it up
to two currents and then we come back to
Johnson's he's got his his championship
room with every vote every fight poster
ricktum like they call out the victim
hall every fight poster just
wallpapering the walls his UFC
championship belts like this is like and
this huge screen and I got to screen for
you my new project this multimedia
comedy special that I'm releasing like
imminently
council real I got I got some of my
buddies who wants to steve-o's one of
his last shows in Albuquerque who
absolutely adores this man and for
medium blight over my best friends and
closest closest friends to watch as
screening and my theater with Steve
Hosting it in between sets and
everything it was mind-blowing
it was it was one I mean yeah my wife
has always said she wants John Legend to
come sing at our wedding I mean that's
that's right up there I mean I don't
know how we're gonna top that
that was amazing experience last night
Steve thank you so much well in that
that movie is gonna be nice guys I feel
like I have a me and my friends have a
secret at the that only we know in the
whole world don't know about it is going
to be nuts when it was over we all felt
emotionally moved inspired in some way I
mean you were vulnerable you you you
gave us visuals with some of the stories
we already know about you it was a lot
man so many different emotions it's it's
something that you that you can't forget
and and everyone has to watch it who are
18 and over okay because there's so many
important questions and there's so many
little things I'm curious about let's
start with your your characteristic your
trademark entrance of the to the I you
enter the Octagon crawling and then the
fight starts and you're on all fours
essentially crawling when the fight
begins yeah yeah and and and what is
that about
my first crawl not up into the cage but
crawl towards one opponent once the
fight started and that was with Rampage
Jackson and then ran space Jackson fight
normally you see two fighters they're
always standing up and and you know John
McCarthy are you ready are you ready
let's get it on right and and both guys
come skipping into each other you know I
feel like I was I was the first fighter
to ever crawl towards an opponent while
the fight the why the time sticking
right you get down sometime you look at
the next guy that cuts you off in line
or something you just get down crawling
up to him so it's intimidating
so with Rampage Jackson I kept having
these nightmares that that I would get
knocked out and no matter how the fight
played out I would always get knocked
out and it was always within the first
30 seconds of the fight so you know once
you know I've run out he'd run at me
Swink a huge over here right the other
he would throw a right uppercut and then
another dream it was a left hook and I
couldn't avoid this inevitable knockout
that I was going to experience in the
first round and you know I'm a big fan
of sports psychology so I call I called
those Redstone thoughts and I actually
learned that from a shot Evans you know
when you have a negative thought
immediately cancel it with a positive
thought you know instead of thinking of
somebody beating your ass you think of
yourself
exhausted your winning fights almost
over just think something positive and I
just couldn't avoid these images and in
actual nightmares of rampage Jeffs and
knocking me out so on fight night I felt
like I was gonna get knocked out and I
felt like this was coming for me I felt
like energetically like I was getting
these signals from a higher power that
like John this is gonna happen to you
tonight and I couldn't avoid it so I
just had this super deep prayer
where I got down on my knees and I and I
touched my body from my head to my toe
for the first time and I pray this
prayer asking God to just give me the
super natural like reaction abilities
from speed flexibility awareness and and
as I was as I was praying this prayer
and touching my myself rubbing myself
and in meaning every ounce of this
thinking my life is on the line I
noticed looking at myself that I was
covered in feathers I was covered in
white this nation it wasn't a
hallucination and it was it was it was
real spoke to you it was very real to me
it was very real to me I could see
myself covered and like there was like
small feathers in between my fingers and
I was covered in feathers and they came
up like to my neck and my face was still
like normal not in competitors but my
hands our feet were covered and I felt
like I was like this fighting thing that
wasn't earthly almost and I like felt
this surge of energy power for
flexibility mental acuity and awareness
and sharpness that I had never
experienced before and I like jumped off
my him my knees and like landed a bull
feet immediately and I was just like
whoa Wow I was just when just like my
coasters is looking at me like like they
could feel like okay he is pumped up and
coach Winkeljohn is like let's hit let's
hit and immediately I kicked the pad and
it was like mmm and it like it like it
was like whoa and like my kicks were
lightning fast and I didn't need to
stretch any more I didn't need to warm
up my lungs anymore my kicks were going
up high I was jumping higher I was
kicking faster and higher it was an
unbelievable experience and I actually
was able to hang on to this feeling and
this illusion of myself being in this
alter ego all the way through the cave
all the way through my walk to the cage
and and I felt like in that Rampage
Jackson five
I walked into that fight as this feather
man for the first time and my my idea to
crawl towards him was the only thing
that had it happened in all my
nightmares right because in every place
I started on my feet so something just
said good on your knees and crawl up to
him and then automatically the dream
voids itself of him knocking you out
immediately right so I did that and I
got to kind of I don't know fighting up
fight an alter ego kind of stayed and it
was super powerful now to this day I say
that same kind of Prayer over myself and
I believe that that I transform it to
something I love that she got a million
things like that you know when you were
in that fight was time slowed down for
you were you're kind of like this is
what time things went slow down but you
you you get to this belief place that
you are that you are more than human at
the moment and then you believe that
things as far as just on every realm are
not designed to go against you at this
moment's this is all you're actually
living in your actual purpose at this
moment this was exactly what you're
designed and born to be doing this is
your mark and and at this moment I'm
being used by my higher power to like a
fuck-shit beautiful story very much I
got a question about the walk out mm-hmm
with with the music like I was so
impressed when you had the the song the
Queen saw the song by the mousse yeah
like you know like did I get goosebumps
from that like what's the lyric I
remember and when on your walk out
science second dude it was incredible
the question is are our fighters allowed
to just pick any song they want they
have to license the music so we are not
allowed to come out to music
that has not been published by like
professional like label and stuff like
that I think that's the way it works so
at before the UFC we would have all the
local kind of homies making your your
local your song or whatever and I think
copyright and lawsuits that people
wanted to get a piece of the UFC oh you
guys played my song on pay-per-view now
I should get a cut and all this type of
stuff so data wise you said hey you know
the ones they I think they played the
fight live when you come out that night
and then even reruns on TV on television
are always but the more known music like
Queen is gonna be considerably more
expensive to license I wonder how that
I've never asked but the UFC I work with
a woman named Heidi who works at the UFC
offices she always does the
customizations of ourselves and and they
can they got some hella DJ's that can
cut up any song any three four five
songs you want the walkout music is just
such a big deal in setting the tone for
the fight yeah I try not to I'm not I
try not to be too superstitious about
you know music and little things like
that just because just in case if
something doesn't go your way say the
music stops or audio goes out or
whatever you're always able to get it
out no matter what state you know so
right okay yeah I don't hang on to the
music too closely but every once in a
while I would try to put subliminal
messages and in the song that I choose
but I don't allow it affect my mental
state that Queen use that Queen tune
right I've used it a few times I've used
it maybe two or three times since the
first time okay yeah but it's a
relatively new thing that's great I
would normally be all over and but right
around flight time do my phone gets
crazy that pisses me off purse I don't
like it either I don't wanna mess with
the fighter I don't want to contact a
fighter like we're feeling you get
because we're gonna distract a man when
he's got a war to go into it's like a
one in you appreciate people reaching
out to you and saying good luck tonight
on the other hand you don't appreciate
people reaching out to you that you
haven't spoke to in a year or several
several months right and then they write
you something of non substance like kick
his ass oh my bro you didn't write me
something right now I feel like my mind
is it's at a high capacity on fight day
like a useful useful useless [ __ ]
[ __ ] it annoys me on fight back say
something and powerful impactful said
give me uh give me give me a scripture
give me something that's gonna like I
can pull from later on tonight don't say
cookies ass cuz me reading that thousand
times today is not helping any tax
disruption I got better advice leave the
[ __ ] man alone let him concentrate
let him be with his team with his
coaches and and and then congratulate
him when he wins yes yes yeah you know I
think that's what people are starting to
learn to do because I never I'm starving
that's it to not reply right before the
fight and I'm starting to get people get
clever enough to write me a whole month
later after a fight they say you know I
see that you want to fight last month
I'm imagining things are finally
starting to calm down for you I wanted
to reach out to you and tell you that
I'm so happy for you but those people
are the ones would get the best
responses from me because I'm actually
in a mental place at that point where I
can actually give you my full attention
to everything like that but you know you
get it when you make a movie everyone
your names everywhere and everyone wants
to be a part of it at that moment and
that's when unfortunately you don't
really have time to go into smaller
conversation the worst is my birthday
you know I've [ __ ] birthdays and
holidays it's just like it's so many
people happy birthday happy birthday and
I know that these are people that are
wishing me well people who care about me
I wish you happy birthday response happy
birthday and I said something else the
answer to something else I [ __ ] hate
because now I make a whole year older
we're drawing attention to have [ __ ]
old I am and my phone is bothering me
all day with I got more work to do
replying to texts then then I mean
you're probably coming across as the
most
[Laughter]
[Music]
I want to take it back to fight day like
what what's that like for you waking up
but you have a routine that you do every
fight that day or is it start before
that or is it like we have pancakes
[ __ ] zoned out yeah my fight day I
wake up I wake up whatever my body looks
me up so you know sometimes that's one
o'clock in the afternoon sometimes
that's 10 a.m. it always varies and the
coaches are always on standby we will
have a breakfast I never eat meat on the
day of a fight I believe that meat do
you hide I jest really slow and it gives
you energy for like the next day or the
day after that day definitely not the
same day you know so I don't mean eat me
on the day of an event
I'll eat meat Friday after my Williams
I'll have some meat probably like a fish
or like a white meat but the day of the
fight I don't have any me and I'll eat a
lot of sugar
I love slow burning sugars I'll have in
the afternoon and a lot of carbohydrates
throughout the day I'll chew on some
rice some yams
you could never be overly hydrated on
Friday so I'm sipping water all day long
are you talking to people or you just
like don't know no I touch to very
certain people on fight day that's my
wife I talked to my my father I talked
to my spiritual leaders spiritual you
know advisors does it suck being the
last fight of the night or would you
rather be first and get it over with I
be in the last fight of the night is all
I have ever known
it's all so mean I came out the womb two
or three fights in the UFC I had before
being the main main event guy the goal
is to be main event guy for the rest of
my career that's the goal the case I
think that's gonna be the case no matter
which way it goes let me ask
this fighters we get the impression are
like really guarded about anybody
knowing what their natural walking
around way it is fighting not me but
when they're on an interview they're
like school can you talk about what your
way now and they didn't ever answer the
question why do you do that
I don't know usually it's a psychology
you don't want your opponents to know
where you're at you know you can tell a
lot about a guy based on where he's at
you know if he's a little tip he's ten
pounds over if he's under it shows you
where his kind of mental is at at that
moment so does it also indicate how much
power might be depleted from him on
awake absolutely - yeah if I know I know
you're 20 pounds over and we're fighting
in two weeks that's that's a huge
psychological health E mm-hmm and then
and then and then mentally to like you
know when you lose 20 pounds in two
weeks you're not gonna you're not gonna
be right not gonna be there so uh and
when you know your opponent's having a
wig tough weight Club I like to really
get tricky with my words and
manipulative and really start to try to
pile on certain things bully the guy
almost it's trying to break him before
the fight even especially if they miss
weight by 0.5 pounds Oh that'd be bad
who you talking about you know I'm
talking about didn't you say when these
to move your fighting DC your life you'd
be the champion of you know six point
five no no no no so if you fight for a
title you have to make two or five point
zero if you're if you're fighting at U
of a UFC G's 205-pound exhibition then
you can weigh in at 206 okay so if a
championship you gotta be 205 I remember
saying that and I was like oh this guy's
down you know like you got it going on
I but I want to preface me talking about
any UFC fighter I am well aware that
they can [ __ ] me up at any time and so
I'm very talking about them very easily
Scott like judgmental about it because
I'm like bro these guys will just
[ __ ] kick my ass so I just don't want
to come off as talking [ __ ] no I didn't
come across that way at all and I do
appreciate you having respect for the
fighters you know a lot of a lot of fans
give UFC fighter
[ __ ] for a lot of different things then
and at the end of the day man we put our
lives on the line to be entertainers you
understand that
you know I mean so there there's always
a certain amount of leeway that I'm
gonna give fighters for certain things
it's a lot that goes into what we do
especially the keyboard warriors are
just [ __ ] a face made top top top top
band but uh you ever seen one of them in
person you're like I know you do no
never in person no I've had maybe one or
two people flat-out tell me in person I
don't like you yeah it's baby happy once
or drunk in over a decade yeah and
they're usually alcohol involved yeah
yeah but um I'm learning to really
appreciate haters because a hater is a
person that is emotionally involved they
care all right it's true they care and
they can be very motivating I've
definitely been more motivated by
negative [ __ ] than I've ever been
motivated by a positive [ __ ] I'm the
same way right I'm saying right now
though honestly being involved with the
care project and being detached from UFC
and trolls and all that type of stuff
this is motivating me way more than a
world championship fight I mean I've
been title fights for so long now I'd
get what that feels like I know what the
after-party feels like I know what it
feels like to be called champ and looked
at as the greatest fighter forever I
already been experiencing these things
for so long now that that [ __ ] doesn't
really tickle me anymore
changing my changing my life and giving
back to other people and and how do
people say thanks for what you did for
the city last night of some of that my
neighbors look at me like like a person
that they're incredibly proud to be
neighbors with that means so much more
to me than being a UFC champion and I'm
so relaxed that's so much more so much
more fulfilling part of me part of me
believes that that's the way it's gotta
be I mean I know it's gotta be that way
because I i-i've for one I had to learn
how to separate my like personal
identity from this like steve-o
character because like I'm just gonna be
barreling towards misery if I don't you
know I got to be able to be healthy
without the career you know have no
future
but I also know it's a little bit like
trickier it's hard it's easier said than
done
you know yeah it's like you got a legacy
to worry about yeah and like when you
say oh that doesn't tickle me anymore it
feels better it feels better Stevo
honestly it feels better to leave my
legacy behind for a while you know I'm
still 30 I'm still 32 years old and
every time I fight I'm taking such a
risk yeah and we got to talk about that
too but first let's talk about your
Twitter and anything I'm just
acknowledging what's out there okay
because did you let it you let it ride
on Twitter right yeah you let it ride on
Twitter and when do you tweet something
it makes news you know and there's been
a lot of people talking about UFC pay
lately you know it came out I think like
last year there was some like revelation
in the media that it's you know most
sporting organizations pay their
athletes 50% of all the revenue the UFC
pays 18% right can you explain what that
means because I hear you say that but I
don't know what that means I think take
all of the revenue 250 all the revenue
that came in from UFC to this because
I've heard it said that the fighters
don't see a penny off the gate I know we
make no money on gate concession merch
we do actually okay much they give us a
check every once in a while and I'm not
trying to goddamn that my employer but
yeah it's definitely it's definitely
nothing to right it'll pay a bill and
definitely not see so many John
jokesters honestly people ask me all the
time where do I get the lion shirt with
the half lion half face and I just like
honestly it's a nice shirt you can get
it probably in the UFC website but if
you're doing it to support me that I
don't get anything off that damaged
t-shirt you know see seven cents per
shirt that's Bobby if that I don't know
I'm glad John said that because I'm
terrified to like you know mess up my
relationship to the UFC because I've
[ __ ] loved going to the fight
and it could be said true that there's
no other game you know what are you
gonna make money going to Bellator well
yeah that's that's the most messed up
thing about about my situation currently
is in any other profession if you're
unhappy with the way you're being
treated or the way you know you're being
paid or whatever you can just you know
take your [ __ ] and leave and and go to
the next boss and see if they value you
more and in my situation I would be
forced to retire from fighting
completely unless I wanted to coach your
own in gym you know my hands are tied so
that nobody's paying 5 million bucks a
night to coach a gym but I do believe
wholeheartedly that that you know the
companies that own Bellator and some of
these other leagues do have the same
amount of backing financial backing that
the UFC had and I do believe that having
John Jones would be the new face of your
promotion especially today when I'm
really making an effort for the first
time to really get my [ __ ] someone
together I do feel good my mass Twi has
done a lot for me man it set me free in
so many ways it embarrassed me it
reality checked me it you know I've
never been on camera drunk for the
public to see like that it was it was
humiliating and somewhat of a bottom for
me and and I'm ready to snap it into
high gear but um but anyways I think
right now is a good time for any company
to have me for sure understand my goal
is to be an asset to any company that
that I'm a part of and I got a I got a
feeling that if I am able to get out of
my UFC contract that I would be huge for
another company for sure you know I just
wish that my relationship with Dana
wasn't the way that it that it is and
it's like I get that you want to make
these hundreds of millions of dollars
off me but if you don't like me anymore
if you sleep flatout don't like me you
could easily say what you wanted what
you want to say but I don't like he
actually likes me I've never had whiskey
night and dinners and and and [ __ ] like
that and I was there man and and you
know I wonder because I believe that our
perception of something can be so wildly
different than the reality of
I don't think I'm his favorite person I
think it's really clear when you watch
one of his interviews when I come up and
my point is that if if that's what it is
if this has gotten to a place of being
personal then I would just much rather
work for a company where I felt like I
went home I'm home when I go to work the
employees and I do have great
relationships well with UFC staff great
relationship with UFC staff but um you
feel like you feel like they don't
really want you there
my perception is different and and when
you say I think Dana doesn't like me
were reacting to the same stuff we're
watching interviews you know it's not a
personal conversation and I my take on
it it's not that he doesn't like I just
think that he's been put on the spot and
John Jones wants more money and then
it's like oh and so you're kind of at
the negotiating table with him in front
of the whole world with the media
covering it all and so I don't think
that it's a question of whether he likes
you as a person or you know or is
respectful of you I just think oh now
I'm being forced to negotiate on a world
stage which is an ideal and so he's just
kind of defending his position in a way
that he I don't think when consider
personal on any level now you're taking
business and you're spilling it out and
- you know I mean that's just what's
happening yeah and so I think that he's
I think he cares for you very much when
I hear him say he could have been LeBron
James I look at that and I think that he
wants you to be the LeBron James you
know I do believe that yeah I think I
think he does like you I think he does
care about you and I think that he's a
shrewd businessman you know and I think
that he's got a monopoly on the entire
sport of MMA so he is in a luxurious
position to pay people what the [ __ ] he
wants to pay him he's basically the man
he's the man and and we're huge fans of
his we're huge fans of yours and you
know I hate to say it to you but I don't
give a [ __ ] who's fighting I'm never
missing a fight hey listen I'm a fan of
the UFC myself the UFC will go on
whether I fight or not I got I got I got
nothing to lose being in the position
that I'm in
you know I you want to fight soon no I
don't want to fight soon I don't want to
fight soon I have no interest in
fighting in the UFC until I get paid
what I believe I'm worth and a lot of
fans like steve-o like just said we'll
continue to watch the UFC and support
the UFC and I have no problem with that
I just ordered the last pay-per-view
myself but I think it's really powerful
when you stand up for what you what you
believe is right and and I think I think
that I think that eventually the UFC
will realize that they're being stubborn
they'll realize that that they do have a
special athlete in myself and I really I
think they'll realize I think they'll
eventually meet me halfway is there a
certain percentage point you want to see
or is there if you can wave a magic wand
to get your needs met what does that
look like that's a good question though
but in it but and I won't get into
specific numbers I'm not asking for
anything outrageous and I know we're in
a pandemic and I know when you're multi
millionaire you asking for more it makes
you seem like this greedy person and all
these type of things I'm very aware of
all this but I'm also very aware that
that that I have the voice in the
platform to make change most of the guys
who are doing the absolute worst are not
in a position that they could say
publicly I have a second job I'm
borrowing money from my parents I know
so many photos that are living in
Jackson's MMA gym because they can't
afford to have their own apartment and
there were UFC fighters and they just so
this is sad and and if I have to have a
bad relationship with Dana sit out for
two years three years to bring to bring
light to bring light to what's happening
let's not sit out for two years to bring
light to what's happening then then this
see these are the things that people
remember you for more than winning belts
the guy stood for the younger fighters
legacy thing it is already sealed the
legacy with with fighting always like
who are you what are you stand for what
are you about and what way are you
innovative trying to change the world
for a better what are you doing because
and I can't I gotta just stop me there
and say it again let's not go two years
without fun
want to say that as it relates to what
you're worth there's something there big
time and I think that you're worth
exponentially more now and this is just
my take this is just my take but I think
you're worth so much more now because
you've been in a place that's the worst
place to be for a UFC fighter where
nobody even [ __ ] necessarily cares
that much because they know you're gonna
clobber your opponent so bad it's just
like okay you know we got a main event
but it's not even like really the
interesting fight because it's such a
blowout it's so one-sided it's like the
problem that Amanda Nunez has right now
Mike Tyson Valentina Shevchenko Mike
Tyson is a little bit of different of a
story because they just wanted to see
how fast it wasn't how how explosive it
was but Amanda Nunez Valentina
Shevchenko John Jones there's names I
can think of where it's like man there's
so there's they don't have a fight who
do you put them up against it's not even
interesting right and now we're I'm
finally at a place where there are big
fights Dominic gray as General Santos
rematch I mean your last chance has
gotten people saying like John Jones
looks human in his last treatment
he seems somehow beatable I'm not
necessarily saying I believe that's the
case but there's there's theories out
there what is that why are you looking
like that
I'm good the city we are bad days at
work I think that's the best thing for
me because now if the belief is out
there if it's in the consciousness that
John Jones is beatable then your
pay-per-view numbers are way up you are
worth way more as a potentially beatable
fighter than you are as the guy that you
know it's gonna be a blowout
I have 100% agree I think that I'm even
more beatable as a heavyweight and
that's why I went to Dana White looking
for a raise
Daniel Cormier got a raise when he went
heavyweight I was looking for a raise to
go heavyweight
Francis Nagano is scary you know there's
a big chance that he could break my jaw
and I'm okay with that
I'm okay with that as a fighter I've
whipped enough as that as someone
eventually gets me then we all have our
day
I'm okay with that but I think that [ __ ]
with an increase of pay I think what
about yeah heavyweight the pay-per-view
numbers are going to go up inevitably
more people are going to watch but I
think Dominic raise again absolutely
absolutely but the fact that the UFC
wasn't willing to budge at all they
didn't want to talk about hey listen
let's pay you a little less let's
enhance this this let's make this their
that it was never zero no negotiation
whether you go heavyweight next whether
used to fight dominant rail snacks
whether you fire yan block a [ __ ] next
you were gonna get paid the same event
the same amount and that's what made me
retire I just okay it was okay but but
the percentage on the pay-per-view you
do get paid more if it sells better I
get paid more
after more people start to buy the fight
so I thought on the first million buys
you know you get like a certain amount
of dollars and then after two you know
after the first hundred thought you
giving them Sam that's all incentive
based sure so yes its back end like I'm
Jackass movies yeah what I wanted was
just the guarantee upfront to to go up a
bit because at the end of the day when I
fight you know I don't I don't know
exactly what the UFC brings in but I'm
assuming it's somewhere wrong it's so
funny how exactly like the movie
business this is because there's two
pieces of our movie contract there's the
upfront money what you're talking about
and then there's the backend money which
is it once the budgets been recouped and
then tries to tell you have to tell you
have to trust them to tell you how many
movies are selling are you obviously and
we've got our lawyers do UFC no one
questions what was happening in the
backstage is no one's really auditing
them to see how many paper user actually
did so you just they could say hey you
sold 200 bars this time and here's your
check or they can say there's been 700
bucks but it's kind of like I'm saying
like hey we're gonna pay the same amount
for jackass 2 then we do for whatever
you know right right of course of course
you should be always and and I think I
think you're because people are turning
in for the possibility that maybe Jon
Jones is gonna get beat especially a
heavy
well a heavyweight more beautiful if
it's got bit it's just simple guys see
they hit so much harder they hit so much
harder so the chances of getting knocked
out is higher but at the same time I've
been facing heavy weights for a long
time and I do really good against those
guys I'm surprisingly really strong
really strong and I'm fast that I just
move well my body mechanics move very
well so I think I can do things that
they just don't do and they they just
can't do it's kind of a question just
getting through the first round with him
and then you just get so tired well
Francis Logano it's very it's very
simple get comfortable with the
worst-case scenario worst-case scenario
is he knocks you the [ __ ] out he
possibly fractures a bone in your face
that's the worst case scenario you get
real comfortable with that idea and then
it becomes easy
if he doesn't knock you out and break
your face you're smart you're fast you
have a chin you have great head movement
you know you can wrestle you can there's
a lot of there's a lot of ways things
things can play out so I just think
about the worst-case scenario and get
yourself mentally to a place where you
almost walking into that like okay I'm
getting ready to go out there and this
guy could possibly hurt me tonight okay
now that I've faced that I've swallowed
that I'm sure you have the similar
conversation before you jump off
something you're like okay this could go
this way sure
so that's the way I look at it so I get
friends about his dangers yes I believe
that he has a chance to knock me the
[ __ ] out let's sit let's say that out
loud but if I don't get knocked out I
believe I win that fight I just gotta
get through round 1 and I wouldn't that
fight yeah how do you want to beat the
gunner you want to knock out or any any
way you can I just want to be the
scariest baddest dude on the planet and
if that's Francis steep a or DC yeah I
just want I just I'm just ready to
finally stop playing games with
greatness and just go for it it's like
John if you if you believe that you have
something that that is special that is
even a gift from your higher power then
stop question it because it's insulting
it's insulting to you that your Creator
that you believe that he will put
limitations on what he's given you
okay man that's huge yeah hi then we're
just about there but I just said
something that was a big deal and he
said I'm get comfortable with the
worst-case scenario
mm-hmm is it an inevitability that
you're gonna fight until there is a
defeat do you want to try to get out
while you're still undefeated my goal is
to get out while I'm still undefeated
but my goal is also to risk it all for
my last few fights I love it I love it I
had a conversation with Ronda Rousey on
her YouTube channel
and she said some some pretty heavy
stuff because notoriously like it was
well known that she took the Holly home
defeat real hard and she took the the
núñez to be even harder you know she was
just in a gnarly place and but then she
came out of it like a healthier person
she told me she said you know I feel
like if I would have left
undefeated if I would have walked away
with the belt
you know like that would have been
selfish she says the way I did it I'd
say I feel good about
I passed the torch you know to there you
know I didn't keep it for myself and
like I mean maybe that's where you wind
up when when you work through something
but my question is like if there is a
defeat what kind of by preparation what
kind of like like like like whatever
head round walks that's a question I
feel like I have taken losses throughout
my whole adult life publicly to be
accused as steroids people you go from
hero to zero immediately in some
people's eyes and even those you saw has
proven that that there's a reason for
those picograms and picograms gives you
zero athletic performance don't look
like a guy was on steroids even though
I'm you daz a steroid user in some
people's eyes for the rest of my life
which which hurts me deeply honestly
that's a defeat you know I lost my mom
you know that's a defeat I lost my
sister to cancer
that's a defeat you know and a
hit-and-run it's a pregnant woman
humiliating and just you looked at as a
monster you know to be able to involved
with
something like that that's a defeat you
know so I've dealt with so much defeat
already and and I feel like my career
has been such a tremendous blessing
already and everything that I do in my
career is just a cherry on top of
something that's already been great yeah
if I were to retire today they said that
kid truly you know came saw and
conquered and you could retire yeah it
could be tired so I look at losing is at
this point in my life as is as John you
are you're already the greatest light
heavyweight of all time a fighter as a
light heavyweight though I'm the
greatest light heavyweight of all time
and I don't think that's arguable right
now so I in my psychology I've already
retired that and and that UFC career is
already on the shelf and now I'm trying
to focus on Who am I as a person on
Saturday that's what I'm talking about
and and got to separate you the person
from you the fighter yes because like
the in suspended also has helped me with
you know I was suspended at one point
for almost two years for that steroid
thing so that helped me start to process
John who are you when you don't have the
UFC to lean on who are you and I've
learned about myself that I right away I
find someone to work out with and and
that gets me off to college and you know
and then right now I have the cure
project and it's the first time in my
life where I finally am a part of
something through this cure project is
is some so big for me it's it's like all
I've ever been my whole life is a father
a man to my girl Jesse a friend you know
and like this this UFC fighter I feel
like my whole image has been based
around
I've been John Jones Jon bones Jones
Jonny bones Jones I'm trying to create a
life of more substance outside the UFC
I'm trying to get to a place where I
don't want to fight anymore or I don't
care about fighting anymore
because we're not getting validation
from that and more I want life that
she's so powerful fulfilling outside of
UFC so that that if I do come back my
ayat my idea will be that I am truly
giving them a gift
this is not for me this is you guys have
paid me enough to get me to come back
and this is for this is for like the
fans of the sport but this isn't
something that I need to do anymore I
want life outside I want I want my
friends to thank yo John is the [ __ ]
best friend to ever be friends with I
want I want my daughters to which they
already do absolutely love me and Amira
me and respect me I want my girl to look
at me like yeah I got the baddest
[ __ ] man ever you know like that's
what that's what that's what that's
where I'm at right now it's like being
the UFC champion doesn't matter to
nobody but but it's gonna call it's
really affect at the end of day me and
my circle right having money who does
that affect me and my kids right being
an athlete don't mean [ __ ] if you're not
doing something with it you're not in
fact impacted somebody else and some
type of positive way our friends family
and and what really matters so the UFC
MMA up and try to get me back before I
develop this identity that has nothing
to do with fighting and not want to go
back what I've noticed about you is I've
always seen you on you know on ESPN and
I've had this idea of you but like
getting to know you over the last couple
days you're really [ __ ] funny dude
and in this care project deal the
biggest thing for me and you know
spending this this the last couple days
with your with your crew man what of the
last couple days mr. Cruise trips been
so epic and I'm talking to your crew
it's like everybody who's involved in
this care project these are the people
who are like a positive influence on you
yeah and I've heard it like you know
I've heard some of the guys say you know
like man if if he stays with this circle
that you're this group of people around
him then like he can't go wrong you know
there but there is like some kind of
other element there's some kind of other
crew yeah like if you wander over and
start
with them it's kind of all bad yeah I
feel like the coronavirus in my last DWI
it the corona virus itself it changed
something in my psychology it just made
me start looking at everyone that I was
hanging out with a little differently
I'm trying to look at like okay I got a
lot of buddies that I go to the bar with
and stuff and since the virus truck it
just helped me look at the people that I
surround myself with and ask me like
okay you know what do I get out of this
friendship what is this doing you don't
need a corona virus to do that's what
really helped me though yeah it helped
me it helped me learn how to stay home
on Fridays and Saturday yeah you know I
you know I I uh my wife she she loves me
to live the way I want you know pretty
much and she doesn't harass me about
going out and stuff like I had with my
boys and stuff so and so before the
world got put on hold I you stopped this
fear of missing out I had to be how I
had to be at the party I had to be doing
something that I considered wild and fun
and and coronavirus really helped me
realize that John you're not missing
anything out there and that everything
that really really matters is happening
during the daytime and in with your wife
with your kids in and coronavirus just
really helped me detach from the night
life and now that it's reopening and you
know people are hitting me let's go here
they open here there's mad people on the
patio over here and now I've learned
this lifestyle of accountability
partners and I'll have my strength coach
you know Garret meet up with me three
days a week and then I'll have my
endurance coach Lawrence meet up with me
twice a week I don't know how my dog
trainers made up three days a week and
then my family to do these little date
nights and my daughter's to box two days
a week and then before you know it
you've locked yourself in with so many
sober people and you can't you know so I
I'm like I got like two or three things
to do almost every day with somebody
who's sober who that's a physical
activity and I don't have time I don't
have time to be getting hungover or
doing stupid stuff right now and and
it's my accountability partners and my
friends close friends and coaches
set me free and it got me operating at
closer to like a 80% level right now
when for the longest time I was
operating at 90 percent in training camp
and then I will go back down to being
about a 40 percent person [ __ ] train
I used to never train dude I used to
just man I just I was smoking ton of pot
in between fights get drunk on the
weekends be going to church on Sunday I
love God with all my heart that that's
something that is very genuine about me
well yeah I had this side of me that
just didn't work hard or try hard at all
I would only try hard and camp in just
being a loser man I was lucky I was
lucky that I didn't get in trouble more
than I actually did did get in trouble
but right now I'm opening up this this
new idea in life I am busy and I'm happy
the first night that we met right like
you came to the green room at the show
like I'm a doing the [ __ ] show and
the venue manager says hey John Jones is
here he's wondering if you could come
back and say hi I'm like what the [ __ ]
no way of course so John comes back we
hit it off we exchanged phone numbers
and I'm like yo dude let's beat up my
ear tonight you cauliflower ear it's on
you we're gonna do it and I'm like okay
I gotta finish my meeting great but then
we'll meet up right and I mean like it's
all good but it seemed kind of evident
to me that you were with bad circle yeah
yeah you know I know everyone knows that
but your sobriety and for a while I felt
like I surrounded myself with people
like to drink and smoke and and so out
of respect for you you know we took off
but right now man I'm at a place where I
realized the responsibility that I have
the platform that I have and and I
realize that people respect you way more
way more for for what can you do for
others for serving then winning
championships dude
winning another championship for
Albuquerque like I do it for my city I
represent the board okay the 505
that's nice what bro yeah donating half
your endorsement money to charities a
month or and doing that type of stuff is
like I feel alive right now dude it's
like it makes you want to behave it
makes you want to keep that go on
behaving for at behaving to be the champ
that's no pressure people expect a world
champion UFC fighter cage fighter to be
a little while you know but when you are
the face of a foundation about care it
forces you to to mature and to elevate
yourself to a to a person that is always
on always on and always trying to do the
right thing so I'm excited to see what I
transition into over the next few years
yeah I mean especially with guys like
you man who's just the freakin former
wild boy who's completely sober now Matt
wow this [ __ ] you always try to stop me
when I'm complimenting you the way the
way that you have changed your life bro
and even seeing your movie last night
made me respect you so much more birla
just you went from such a I'll say dark
place man
- just now you just [ __ ] you just
filled with a smile and and just you're
trying to use all that same fire and
energy to change the world for the
better and I'm honored to be your friend
bro like I want to look at you as
someone as a mentor to people like Steve
as a mentor steve-o as John Jones is
meant to I think I think I think you'd
be a good ear thank you so much and I
hope that you know any any part of this
it was like wasn't there wasn't any part
of this there was like rude or
disrespectful or anything because I have
like so much respect when you were in
the pool yeah pull your shorts up all
the way my wife hates seeing your ass
correct I could say - I love you John
John what a bitchin episode and you know
what else is really [ __ ]
this signed 8 by 10 print of that
building jump yeah they're available
already at Stevo comm so please head on
over there and get it because 100% of
the revenue is going straight to the
Roadrunner Food Bank of New Mexico Plus
look right there that signature looks
just like a dick that's why I call it a
Ditka graph yeah and it's only 25 bucks
which buys up to a hundred and twenty
five meals for hungry New Mexicans so
please do the right thing get yourself
this super dope signed 8 by 10 and you
know the street team I got I love you
guys
thank you so much and yeah we'll see you
next week Wow